boa tarde
vocês já pararam para pensar os
significados do sucesso para vocês
o sucesso depende apenas do esforço de
cada um
gostaria de fazer um relato pessoal
sobre esse aspecto
eu me chamo fiani tenho 30 anos e me
considero uma pessoa bem receptiva
sou estudante de doutorado em breve me
tornarei uma professora pesquisadora em
uma universidade não há nada nesse país
em 2009 quando a companhia adaptação
passei a fazer parte 16% da população
brasileira com ensino superior completo
quando concluiu o mestrado passei a
fazer parte de 0 35% da população em
2018 quando estiveram e doutorado
concluído passarei a fazer parte de 0,09
fechando a população último de doutores
os dados também mostram que os doutores
recebe em média 35% a mais do que os
mestres que por sua vez recebe em torno
de 85% a mais que os graduados
considerando que os meus pais se quer
concluir o ensino fundamental
certamente posso dizer que sou uma
mulher bem sucedida
eu sou eu fui eu eu talvez tenha
aparecido estranho para alguns de vocês
que eu tenha vindo aqui para falar de
coisas tão pessoais para outros nem
tanto
afinal estamos tão acostumados e com a
nossa busca incessante por ser as
pessoas bem sucedidas vamos atrás de
conhecimentos de cápsula de conhecimento
sistematizado tanto melhor se
transformados em dicas práticas
o processo de individualização que nós
chegamos hoje e os estudos têm mostrado
justamente o quanto estamos forçando com
a exacerbação dos indivíduos
eu trouxe dados tão fortes e também
individuais para mostrar a minha
história foi justamente porque joguei
muito difícil falar de mim de modo tão
individualizar um estudo realizado pela
dora maria dias sobre os livros de
auto-ajuda mostram que o grande
anunciado da contemporaneidade é esse
a chave é o indivíduo como sou eu a
pessoa privilegiada
estar aqui também posso escolher o que
quero dizer
e posso sem problema algum narrar a
minha história e é de certo modo isso
que eu farei
só que deixe me fazer uma ressalva há
várias formas de contar a sua história é
tanto possível fazer daquela forma
individualizada como iniciei ou então
falar de algumas pessoas ou de algumas
situações que me tornaram um sujeito que
eu sou hoje
justamente o que eu gostaria de fazer
com aquela provocação inicial era
convidar vocês a pensarem comigo em como
sociedade que rumos estamos dando para
as formas de vida coletiva
será que ainda há formas de vida
coletiva não é novidade para ninguém
pois somos animais racionais e que por
isso nos consideramos o centro do
universo
na verdade somos aqueles animais
racionais que vivem em sociedade e que
se adaptam à sua cultura mas também
somos aqueles animais que mais dependem
do outro para sua sobrevivência
na realidade vamos depender do outro por
toda a nossa vida
por esse motivo os primeiros grupos
humanos desde os primórdios de deus e
articularam dependendo dessas vidas
coletivas e formando aqueles núcleos que
nós chamamos de família
ao falar que superei dos meus pais ao
dizer que eu concluir o ensino superior
ea pós graduação enquanto eles nem
sequer conseguiram concluir o ensino
fundamental eu não falei mais importante
que os meus pais de modo sempre muito
humilde sensato fizeram maior esforço
para que minha irmã e eu pudéssemos
estudar e isso garantiu liberdade para
que pudéssemos escolher o que
gostaríamos de ser no futuro e que sem
eles jamais de estaria aqui hoje pois
afinal de contas embora eles não tenham
estudado o estudo nunca deixou de ser
uma prioridade nossa família
por mais que tenha sido sempre uma boa
aluna chega algum momento da nossa vida
em que há pessoas tão boas ou melhores
quanto nós ingressar no doutorado
confesso para vocês foi uma tarefa um
pouco difícil tive que fazer o processo
seletivo mais
uma vez e mais que uma universidade
receber ou não quando você quer algo com
muita força e acredita muito naquilo é
de fato algo bastante dolorido e você
pensa em desistir
eu jamais existiria mas eu não sou
responsável sozinha por isso a minha
orientadora do mestrado e agora
doutorado
mais que uma vez me disse viviane não
desista tenta de novo vai atrás tem
todas as condições mas o que mais me
surpreende nessa mulher e também outras
pessoas é a capacidade que ela tem e que
outras pessoas têm obviamente de
conduzirem o caminho do outro de fazerem
perguntas ainda sem respostas de
provocarem o pensamento sem nunca
intervir em nas escolhas pessoais os
seus orientandos por essa razão a pessoa
bem sucedida que eu sou está diretamente
relacionada a chance de conviver com
pessoas especiais como as que eu tenho
por diversas vezes os temas que
escolhemos nos colocam situações
desafiadoras
isso acontece porque estamos
profundamente implicados naquilo que
lemos
escrevemos e pensamos quando se trata
das ciências humanas as questões éticas
e políticas estão sempre implicados de
jogador são o meu tema de pesquisa
dentro das relações étnico-raciais a
negritude e à educação
como vocês sabem esse tema ele é
polêmico envolve muitas discussões que
por muitas vezes acaba mostrando o
quanto as pessoas não têm qualquer
conhecimento histórico e só corroboram
para a permanência do racismo no brasil
estudar o racismo no brasil ea negritude
de modo geral está aqui diretamente
relacionada à cor da pele e isso envolve
um posicionamento direto dos
pesquisadores se o pesquisador é negro
ou é branco como no meu caso há um
posicionamento ao lugar que ele ocupa
que não consegue escapar
é com muita alegria que enfim vemos um
crescimento muito grande de
pesquisadores negros e é com toda a
razão e os pesquisadores negros e outras
pessoas bem
denunciando a histórica classificação do
negro no brasil e por muito tempo ao
invés de ser considerado um sujeito de
pesquisa foi considerado como objeto
por esse motivo ao entrar nessa seara
tenho feito um maior esforço por poder
dialogar com o movimento negro com
pesquisadores negros e poder pensar de
outro modo de outros modos a educação
das relações étnico-raciais quando na
banca da minha definir a defesa da minha
dissertação de mestrado
a minha pesquisa foi indicada para
publicação em livro passei a trabalhar
nesse projeto
imaginem o livro poderia dar um retorno
imediato para a comunidade onde realizei
a pesquisa e poderia também se tornar
uma fonte de pesquisa para aquele local
a pesquisa que realizei foi ainda não
soares o grande do sul em 2010 nesse ano
em 2015 em julho a publicação saiu com o
apoio da ong alforria e também de outras
pessoas e é muito bom poder compartilhar
um livro para além da academia que acima
de tudo está preocupado em estudar o
outro está preocupado em mostrar os
tensionamentos e o quanto os meios de
comunicação as mídias e no caso do
jornal produzem o sujeito
nesse caso o sujeito negro mas a maior
alegria poder mostrar com pesquisa com
um argumento sólido o quanto o negro é
importante para o espaço ele ocupe
especialmente porque esse espaço foi
historicamente invisibilizado algumas
vezes entrar em determinados espaços
geram algumas dúvidas algumas surpresas
uma coisa que sempre me perguntam é
porque uma mulher branca de origem alemã
se interessaria por esse tema é
curiosidade vai aumentando na medida em
que as pessoas vêm que de fato esse é um
tema que me move e o quanto me incomoda
a ponto de dar aquela dor no estômago
sabe toda vez que a gente fica sabendo
de algumas situações situação de
permanência de desigualdade ou então de
discriminação
como pode a cor da pele e causar
situações tão grotescas
shows e por ser tão ao escolher a
temática racial e por ser uma mulher
branca eu sei que estou em condição de
privilégio e isso confesso para vocês é
uma coisa que me incomoda profundamente
mas ser uma pesquisadora branca que
estuda a negritude acima de tudo
representa estar em contato direto com
autoridade o que ocorre também com as
pessoas negras que estão próximas a mim
no dia da do lançamento do meu livro em
venâncio aires recebiam com um apelido
um tanto quanto engraçado e que me
deixou muito feliz
o apelido de uma mulher negra muito
querida que passou a me chamar de afro
dote
há poucos dias recebi um convite também
muito especial para compor a comissão
julgadora da escolha da mais bela negra
do rio grande do sul evento que ocorre
em santa cruz do sul anualmente ativista
negra e minha amiga inclusive e
organizadora do evento que me fez o
convite disse viviane filme consegue um
currículo para que eu possa mostrar que
mesmo sendo branca entende do assunto
ainda há poucos dias esse ano ao
apresentar a minha pesquisa em um evento
científico
uma pessoa me sugeriu que o certa vez
fizesse uma fala sobre o tema claro
atrás de uma cortina para somente depois
abrir a cortina e desse modo surpreender
as pessoas que estariam assistindo como
vocês podem perceber esse tema essas
situações mostram o quanto estamos
marcados pela representação por muito
tempo a maioria dos pesquisadores eram
brancos e hoje felizmente essa situação
está se invertendo
mas não sem conflitos em tensionamentos
em estações
tudo isso é de certo modo muito
produtivo desde que fique claro que a
luta contra o racismo é de todos é de
brancos e negros e que fique claro o que
todos nós temos condições de contribuir
com isso claro que desde que esteja
muito presente qual é o posicionamento
que ocupamos
estudar o outro e compreender o outro é
uma das questões mais importantes das
ciências humanas e somente conseguiremos
fazer isso
se rompermos com o individualismo o
processo de individualização iniciado no
século 16
talvez tenha chegado ao seu limite não
somos mais capazes de conviver com
pessoas diferentes de nós de sentarmos e
discutimos idéias diferentes sem nos
incomodar profundamente a diferença
parece cada vez nos incomoda mais
uma pesquisa recente realizada na
universidade harvard mostra a
necessidade cada vez maior de profissões
que tenham a condição e profissionais
que consigam trabalhar em equipe que
possam trabalhar com o outro e trabalhar
com pessoas diferentes disse
o estudo também mostra que apesar da
tecnologia ter extinguido com algumas
profissões outras tantas surgiram muitas
delas aliadas a capacidade cooperação
esse é um tema que também abordado pelo
sociólogo richard sennett e um dos seus
livros cujo título não por acaso se
chama juntos
acima de tudo é fundamental que a gente
pare pra pensar na exacerbação do
indivíduo ea escola talvez seja a chave
para esse rompimento para esse essa
exarcebação para esse procon quanto a
gente vem reforçando o individualismo na
contemporaneidade e isso já vem sendo
mostrado pelos mais diferentes pesquisas
nas mais diferentes áreas
faz muito tempo que os governos e outras
instituições já perceberam a importância
da escola
afinal é o único local pelo qual passam
todas as pessoas mas também há pessoas
que defendem a extinção da história da
escola
questionando a sua importância já que
agora na sociedade do conhecimento todos
deveríamos aprender o tempo inteiro
cidade da aprendizagem garante isso pra
quê e pré-escola certo
júlia varella provoca a escola foi
inventada ela também pode desaparecer ea
escola foi inventada na escola para
todos tal qual o modelo que nós
conhecemos
hoje foi criada apenas o início do
século 20 mas a verdade é que a escola
ea sala de aula são os lugares da
cooperação por excelência é aquele local
em que a gente em que a criança eo
adolescente vão e conseguem conviver
aprender a conviver com o outro aprende
a viver em sociedade
aprendendo também o seu na importância
do seu lugar do mundo e um lugar do
outro
nesse mundo hannah arendt filósofa diz
que educação é colocar tornar o
indivíduo sujeito através do seu
conhecimento e da sua cultura
fizemos isso hoje é muito pelas veias da
individualização reforçando cada vez
mais o individualismo e colocando e
tornando o sujeito esquecendo que nós
nos tornamos sujeito justamente por ser
e conviver com o outro ao exercitar mos
a cooperação desde as questões mais
simples no nosso cotidiano como tomar
café com amigos ou participar de uma
reunião com diferentes com pessoas
diferentes países
estamos exercitando a nossa capacidade
de conhecer o outro e também de conhecer
a nós mesmos
cn chama essas capacidades dialógica a
prática das relações dialógicas
tornariam mais mais produtivos os
espaços de convivência entre amigos
entre família entre vizinhos os espaços
de trabalho e como consequência seríamos
mais felizes
esse sentimento de felicidade aliado à
causado pela vida com o outro e aliado
ao sentimento de que eu realmente faça
alguma coisa importante para contribuir
nesse mundo para mim é um dos sentidos
mais importantes do sucesso
mas o sucesso depende de cada um
um conceito ele varia para cada pessoa
embora o capitalismo neoliberal nos
limita inúmeras mensagens todos os dias
dizendo que ser uma pessoa bem sucedida
é ser um executivo de uma empresa e
acima de tudo ganhar muito dinheiro para
mim o sucesso está muito mais
relacionado à capacidade de sermos
reconhecidos por aquilo que fazemos bem
e que amamos fazer o reconhecimento
as pequenas coisas desde um olhar de uma
criança que percebe o quanto você
acredita nela
ou então aquele abraço orgulhoso dos
seus pais que se dão conta de que assim
como eles ensinaram para você
o mais importante não é o que você tem e
sim em quem você se tornou eu viviane
sou uma pessoa que precisa do outro que
me conste tua partir desse outro e que
sou muito feliz por justamente estar
rodeada de pessoas que eu posso ouvir e
que também escuta
para mim esse é o verdadeiro sentido do
sucesso
mas fica o convite para pensar o que
produzo sucesso para cada um de vocês
foi um prazer muito obrigado